health is a good
and health is part of the good life as a
matter of fact health is part of the
long life so if you want to be able to
enjoy it you know your doctors probably
probably giving you fairly good advice
and medicine is Advanced you know quite
a bit but they actually have quite a few
good ideas back in that time and Eric
summercast is sort of a typical
representative of the medical profession
at the time the Medical Art is one of
the oldest arts or Sciences around it
goes you know back to the the beginnings
you know philosophy spun off a lot of
other disciplines all those were you
know originally part of philosophy
Natural Sciences were called natural
philosophy and they got spun off
um
medicine was around before that
mathematics was also around another M1
too music so